important if you're going to treat
massive data sets and really massive a
lot of we're talking about high
dimensions but
uh the word massive data has not really
kind of come up directly
as much as you might hope it would and
so this topic
the broad vision of it is very important
thank you thank you for the introduction
thank you for the invitation it's
a real pleasure to be here
i'm going to talk today about this topic
of streaming i was originally given
title streaming i kind of stretched it a
little bit because i think
this topic was sort of developed over
the past 15 20 years with a lot of
activity
um and this word streaming it sort of
originally came about with the idea that
um you're going to process a large
amount of data
and you know it's going to be so massive
you can't really even think about
looking at all of it at once what if you
can only look at a piece of it at a time
so in particular if we think of this
data as sort of being
formed from lots of little pieces that
sort of tell us about
some small thing that's going on so that
the overall data set is with the
aggregation
of all these small pieces what can we do
if we just sort of look at
things one piece at a time and put them
together
but actually um the techniques that i'm
going to talk about are slightly more
general than that so i'm going to try
and sort of
emphasize that these don't just apply in
this sort of read want setting but they
apply in a slightly more general case
which will
help us get more of a handle on scaling
computations up to very large data set
sizes
so i'm in the fortunate position that uh
like most other speakers i don't really
need to
give any motivation for this at all uh
michael's opening talk on
tuesday basically laid the groundwork
and gave us all the motivation we need
for thinking about problems over large
data um
so let me sort of try and boil down to
the essence of what sort of the idea at
the heart of this area
um the idea is is is
really quite simple it says well if
you've got a very large amount of
information a very large amount of data
that's really too big to work with
conveniently it doesn't fit on your
computers it's too big to even sort of
read in
all together then let's just make it
smaller
and work with a smaller representation
of the data
so the real question at the heart of
this area is to say well how can we
make our data sets small enough to be
convenient to manipulate
small enough to be able to sort of fit
on a on a single machine even on a
single laptop
so what we're really looking for are
ways to summarize
large amounts of data in such a way that
we can argue this summary is going to be
effective
is going to capture whatever features
whatever attributes of the data that
we're interested in
with sufficient accuracy um up to the
fact that we're going to hit some
obvious limitations there are going to
be some some things where where there is
going to be no summary
but in general we you know for a lot of
problems there are a lot of positive
results that say we can build these kind
of summaries
um and and so we're going to think about
well when can we construct them and what
are some of the techniques we can use to
build these summaries
what kind of guarantees will they give
us for working with this kind of data
so firstly you know what how do we
formalize a summary i'm going to shy
away from giving a precise mathematical
definition of a summary
on the ground that in most cases will
know it when we see it
um but you know at a more sort of
high level view well a summary should be
something that's fairly small
uh ideally something that we'll be able
to keep in in fast storage in a
in a computer and for it to be at all
useful
we have to be able to get to that
summary so we have to be able to build
that summary
fairly effectively we have to be able to
update it as we see more information
arriving
and we have to interact with that
summary to get information out
so you know thinking sort of
computationally almost thinking about
how would i start
to program one of these well i need to
start thinking about how would i create
an empty summary
and for most cases that's going to be
fairly straightforward because the entry
summary is going to be the empty set
how do i update that summary as i see
maybe one new piece of information
and if i sort of incrementally keep
updating my summary with each successive
piece of information
that captures this this notion of
streaming computation that i alluded to
at the start
but more generally i'd also like to say
well if i've made a summary of my data
and you've made a summary of your data
using the same process
and maybe even using some similar
parameters then there ought to be a way
that we can merge those two summaries
together
to obtain a summary of the union or the
aggregation
of those two collections of data
and if we can additionally have this
sort of merging property
then this gives us something stronger it
lets us start thinking about
distributing
the computation over multiple machines
over partitions of the data set
and and again you're talking about how
do we start thinking of scaling all the
techniques we've heard about so far to
you know truly massive amounts of data
distribution splitting
the computation over multiple machines
letting us run you know tens hundreds or
thousands of machines
in parallel is really going to be key to
that so anything that allows us to do
distribution
uh and also makes our lives easy enough
that we don't have to worry too much
about fine-grained
synchronization and coordination across
the machines
is is going to help us work towards that
goal
and lastly you know obviously to get any
value after this summary i've actually
got to be able to interact with it i've
got to be able to interrogate it
so i have to go to this summary and sort
of answer some notion of a query
and what that query is is going to be
dependent on
the kind of problem that i'm thinking
about the kind of summary that i've
built
so so rather in a rather cavalier
fashion i sort of threw in this term
sufficient statistics
to say that you know we're used to the
idea of sufficient statistics
um of being here what what's the
information that we need to keep to
capture
um you know crucial information about
distribution well in some ways
that you can think of as a
generalization of that notion it's
trying to say what are the sufficient
statistics for
a broad range of different computations
can we keep them in such a way that it's
we can update those sufficient
statistics
as we see more draws from our
distribution
the other thing i want to sort of bring
into this um
you know i i was really excited about
this idea of sort of the boot camp and
bringing together
people from a wide variety of
backgrounds um i sort of said well we'll
bear in mind
that you're going to be addressing not
just people from your own little
niche of computer science but people
more from mathematical backgrounds from
statistical backgrounds machine learning
and other areas
so i don't necessarily know the best way
to address that wide an audience but at
least what i can do is maybe try and
expose
some of the the axioms and assumptions
that i realize are sort of inherent in
the style of working that i i follow and
that others around me follow
so i tried to say well what
characterizes sort of the computer
science approach
to dealing with with these kind of
questions
um and so the first thing i came up with
is said well we're very cynical
um we're concerned with the price of
everything
um actually this is something that again
michael mentioned um in his
characterization of computation in in
perhaps slightly more favorable terms
on tuesday which is the computation the
study of computation is primarily study
of
the use of certain resources right
so in particular when we're thinking
about building these summaries
what we're interested in are the
resource of space the size of this
summary the the
number of pieces of information we need
to describe this summary
we're also interested in in this notion
of time as a resource
as we process more information how much
time does that take
to process each update or when we when
we pose one of these queries to the
summary how much time does that take
these concepts are going to be
interrelated with some notion of of how
accurate
an answer do we get we're not going to
expect you know a perfect answer because
we're giving away
expressiveness because we're coming up
with this compact representation
then necessarily we're going to be um
coming up with some approximation
and we want to bring in some
characterization of that approximation
into
the space and the time required for
processing this
the other thing that i think is is maybe
not something that we necessarily think
of first but actually comes into
this particular notion of computation is
another resource
that we treat as being somewhat limited
is
randomness i'll explain exactly what i
mean by that in a moment but basically
many of the technique pretty much every
technique i'll talk about involves
using randomization tossing some random
coins
and often what we need is we need to um
return to those random coins later right
i toss some coins
based on seeing a certain piece of
information and later i want to retrieve
the value of those coins
so effectively the amount of randomness
that my procedure use
uses plays into this notion of the space
required
so we actually have to start thinking
about randomness as another resource to
worry about
um what else okay so we're cynical we're
also pessimistic
um what does that mean it means i'm not
going to make any
any charitable assumptions about what
i'm presented with
i'm not going to actually make any
strong assumptions about the the
distribution of the input
right in fact this is i think this is
quite a non-statistical way of looking
at it you know
when when michael's talking about you
know are you a frequentist or a bayesian
this is sort of a
an additional category which is none of
the above you know
we don't really believe uh we don't
really sort of
assume randomness um in the input data
we just say that input data is fixed
but we'd also don't assume a prior on
sort of the parameter space we're
looking at often what we're saying is we
want to do a certain kind of computation
which has a particular answer on
the fixed data and new the whole
randomization the randomness
in the process that we use is something
that actually we bring in to the
computation we
design algorithms that toss coins uh and
bring in randomness that way
um so yeah and and may in many cases you
know i think this is debatable we
we can get into longer discussions
offline about how maybe we should be
making
more you know allowing ourselves more
assumptions about the input distribution
but essentially
this this is a you know this this means
that the pessimist is never disappointed
we don't make any assumptions about the
input so the results we get hold you
know whatever the input distribution is
so things can only get better if we can
start making assumptions about input
distributions
um i'm going to borrow a phrase from
les valiant uh probably approximately
correct
the kind of the way we want to state our
results are
in this sort of probably approximately
correct framework that is we want to say
well
you know there's some notion of the true
answer and we're within some
epsilon confidence interval around that
with probability at least one minus
delta
and what that means is that the tools we
use are the ones we've been hearing
about all week
ones around concentration of measure i'm
actually gonna mostly use just the the
very basic ones
markov chebyshev and turn off bounds
in principle you know we can go on and
use
stronger stronger concentration results
as well
um and and just sort of expanding on
that point i was making earlier
um yeah randomness is a limited resource
we often want to think about randomness
as being you know truly random but also
in some sense a function of of some
index i so that when i see i again i can
retrieve those bits of randomness so
either that means i must explicitly
store
random bits or actually the trick that
we'll be using a lot of is is to say
well
i'm not actually going to explicitly
store that randomness i'm going to
sort of think of using a hash function a
function that appears random
but and is a function is a function of a
much smaller number of random bits
so that i can apply that hash function
to i and retrieve
um the same randomness as a function of
i
but still analyze this process and argue
that
you know that this gives us the
guarantees that we want
um so often i'll be trying to reason
about what kind of randomness we need
what what strength of independence of
randomness we need
um and in a few cases we do sort of
shrug and say actually it's easy to
analyze if we just assume full
independence and
sort of push the issue of exactly how
that's materialized in small space
to one side
certainly in this presentation i'm not
going to be too concerned about constant
factors
so we're going to be in the realms of of
big o notation
um and and sort of forgetting about
those and again as these sort of
techniques transition close to practice
people do start caring more about
constant factors and i'll mention a
couple
of examples along the way about where
people are using these techniques
and where they're trying to actually not
just look at
the costs in big notation but really
squeeze out what those leading constants
are
um so let's let's think now about
how i should how i'm going to interact
with the data so as i've alluded to
we're often going to think of this this
massive quantity of data
as being represented as a collection of
fairly simple tuples
and you know the problems i'm going to
phrase
initially are actually relatively simple
to state
the reason that we're going to going to
treat them as hard and need all this
machinery to work with them is because
we have to
scale things up deal with the
dimensionality of the input
and and do the do simple computations on
large amounts of data
in a non-trivial way
so i'm going to sort of give two models
um
that sort of capture this notion that's
going to be general enough to to give us
quite a lot of different
um problems to think about so the
simplest model is this arrivals only
model that says
um we can think of the data as just sort
of arriving incrementally
this is sort of a weighted arrival model
so here this this sort of
partial input says i see you know three
arrivals of x
two arrivals of a type y two more
arrivals of x so in aggregate you know i
have
five a weight of five associated with
um item x a weighted two associated with
with item y you know that captures
pretty much you know quite a lot of
situations you can think of
a lot of the techniques i'm talking
about were originally motivated in the
context of
understanding traffic on the internet so
you can think of this as sort of
representing packets on a network and
you're tracking you know
which of the most popular destinations
the second model um generalized this
slightly and just says well as readers
as well as positive weight updates i can
also tolerate
negative weight updates so you know i
see some
arrivals for x see some rivals y but
maybe i also see some departures for x
and it turns out that in some cases um
dealing with the model where we only
have to deal with arrivals with
increments
can be easier can can give us a slightly
stronger results
than the model where we we more general
model where we can also
tolerate sort of departures or
decrements
so so that's sort of the setup for um
for today so today's outline uh i'm
going to be covering mostly
problems concerned with sort of
extracting functions from vectors
so we're thinking of that stream or that
collection of inputs
as defining one very
large high dimensional vector and we're
going to start pulling out information
about that vector
so i'm going to talk about sort of
frequency distributions and and
just just very quickly introduce the
concentration balance we're going to
make use of
start talking about some of the sketches
for pulling out say the most significant
peaks in these frequency distributions
talk about
uh essentially a result that parallels
or almost equals the johnson linda
strauss
dimensionality reductions we've already
heard about talk about
you know another basic computation which
is just saying well what's the l0 norm
what's the number of non-zero entries
in this vector effectively what's the
number of distinct elements that i've
seen in my stream
uh and if time at the end talk about
some of the more complex uh computations
um that people have looked at um
going on to sort of a preview of what
we'll get to tomorrow tomorrow we're
going to
sort of pick out a few uh advanced
topics
on in this realm so we're going to look
at sort of sampling techniques and
particularly
some of the recent work around around
what's called lp sampling
and how that applies to graph and
frequency moment computations
we'll look at some matrix computations
that will echo
a lot of the things we heard from
michael and petros already
and i'll also try and talk a little bit
about lower bounds
what are the limitations of what we can
achieve here what are
can we actually show bounds that say if
you want a summary
for this particular problem it needs
with this kind of accuracy it needs to
be at least this big
um and that there's no way of getting a
smaller summary
okay
what we'll start with now is is this
notion of of frequency distributions and
the reason
is you know it's very natural it's very
easy to reason about and it turns out
that a lot of the the core techniques
from streaming and sketching apply to
this question
questions surrounding frequency
distributions
so very basic you know i showed you
those two models where you have
some collection of items and information
about arrivals and departures
of those items so at any instant you can
say well let fi be the number of
occurrences of
item i then you can start saying well
just
on those fi's alone i can ask lots of
meaningful questions right i can say
can you retrieve uh information about
those those indexes i
that have large associated frequencies
uh can we find the number of um
fis that are non-zero effectively the
number of distinct
elements that we've seen this notion of
frequency moments is absolutely core to
the work on streaming it it sort of
started this this
whole line of work back in 96 it sort of
gave the current emphasis behind it
because um
these turn out to sort of um
impact lots of other questions down the
line but but equally you know just on
their own are interesting so we want to
know
um these sort of tantalizingly simple
looking calculations can we just compute
the kth power of the frequencies summed
up
so in particular if f1 is just
the sum that's going to be trivial f2 we
can think of
equivalently as being the squared
euclidean norm so this is going to be
very tightly connected back to
johnson linda strauss and higher moments
have their own interpretations
okay hopefully this is this is going to
be completely
familiar to everyone we're going to make
a lot of use of concentration bounds
um because we're going to follow a
particular pattern
in a lot of cases for a lot of problems
we're going to think about
building an appropriate uh estimator
for some quantity of interest
and we want to give confidence bounds on
that estimate so we're going to
you know think of our estimator as a
random variable and use
concentration bounds around that so that
we can end up with some statement like
this that says that
probability that our estimate is close
to
our target answer within some epsilon
times some some
other quantity y um probability that
we're far
from our target is going to be at most
delta
okay
so what's the starting point for
concentration bands the starting point
is the mark of inequality
um again i think we should all be pretty
familiar with this that
what we're going to be able to say is at
the end is just that the probability
that a random variable exceeds uh some
constant k
is bounded by the expectation that
random variable over k i just find it
very
refreshing and grounding to realize that
you can you know prove this statement on
a single slide
so there's not really any magic here
it's just a matter of
relating any random any non-negative
random variable
to the probability of exceeding that
that value k
so this this term this is in some sense
relatively
weak it doesn't say something very
strong but actually even in this form it
turns out to be useful and obviously
it's going to be the starting point for
many of the other concentration bounds
we'll make use of
so i i i in the title i use this word
sketch
um and and you know the idea of sketch
is sort of evocative of just you know
sketching a drawing
we're going to think about how do we
sketch
this large amount of information
so in particular i want to think about
a way of building a summary where i can
think of it as a linear transformation
of the input
in other words my sketch my summary that
i'm going to build
of of my input x i'm going to be able to
think of it as
just some some sketch matrix s
multiplying x and
why is that convenient well it's
convenient because you know it
immediately gives us this nice linearity
property that
if i have two inputs x and y then i can
build a sketch of
any linear combination of x and y just
by taking linear combinations of their
sketches
what that means in the framework that i
said at the start is that if i want to
think about updating
my summary if i want to think about
adding one new piece of information
then that's that's kind of trivial in
this setting because i just have to look
at
the sketch matrix applied to that one
new piece of information and add that
onto
my running sketch and if i want to merge
two sketches i just sort of
add them up entry wise
however i'm not going to really adopt
this this sketch matrix
representation i'm going to actually
describe most of these sketches in terms
of
hash functions and the reason for
adopting this is just that if these hash
functions are
are simple then this sketch is going to
be very fast to operate
and it's going to have a very compact
representation right i don't really want
to think about actually materializing
this
sketch matrix s because that's going to
be larger than the data that i'm working
with so i'm always going to be looking
for an implicit representation
of this kind of sketch matrix
and and as i talked about before we're
going to
deal with with um randomness
i'm going to think about these hash
functions as as being
sort of limited independence what that
means is that um
if i say a hash function is ky as
independent
um then if i look at the sort of the
hash values of up to k
different indices um
then the probability of of how those are
mapped to values looks approximately
uniform
right and the nice thing about this is
easy however
over the last decades we've built quite
a strong theory around this kind of ky's
independent
hash function so in particular we know
for small values of k
we're in a very good place we can get
this kind of ky's independence
with a hash function that requires just
space k to represent
the the randomly chosen parameters of
that hash function
okay so so here's a first sketch
uh just to sort of warm us up and then
then we'll get into the more complex
sketches
so suppose i want to test if if two
binary vectors are equal right so i want
to sort of say
look at look at these two vectors say
are they equal or they're not equal
right so if i've got them both in front
of me and i can kind of run through them
that's fairly straightforward but can i
build a sketch that lets me
do this can i build some compact
representation of each vector so that i
can
very quickly test if they're equal or
not
so this is this is something that
computer scientists will probably be
quite familiar with
what we want to do is exactly sort of
materialize the right kind of hash
function
to apply to these vectors
and store just the hash function of the
vectors
and argue that the if these two hash
functions give us
the same value on x and y then
there's a very small chance that x and y
differ
however x and y are chosen um with the
assumption
you know they're chosen without
knowledge of the randomness used to
to create the the hash function
so how should we choose this this hash
function is that going to let us test
this equality
what we're going to do is is choose a
hash function of this form
we're going to think of the hash
function of this vector x
as being the sum over indexes i
of the ith entry of x times
r raised to the power i uh over the
prime field p
where r is is our randomness r is chosen
in the range one up to p minus one
so you know why is why is this
firstly why it is a sketch it's a sketch
because if we look at it
what we're doing is we're just computing
a linear transform
of x i of x right all the x i's appear
just as
um linear linear scale scale by a linear
quantity
and add it up
why does this work it's a relatively
straightforward exercise basically
it comes down to the fact that we're
evaluating a polynomial
at a randomly chosen location and then
we can just argue that the chance
that two different polynomials
evaluate to zero is proportional to the
degree of those polynomials
and that if so if we choose
the size of the field over which we do
the computation large enough
then the probability of finding a hash
collision in this way
is going to be small enough that
everything's going to work
so okay so that says that actually for
this very basic question of just saying
is this one massive data set equal to
this other massive data set
and that's something we can build a
sketch that meets our requirements
very effectively but in general we want
to do something a little bit more than
just testing equality
yes yeah yeah
i am probably going to switch notation
around that a few times but i'm going to
try and
notionally we should try and stick to
thinking of n as the dimensionality
okay
okay so um
let's let's look at a slightly more
complicated sketch
um so here's a sketch that's going to
help us
pull out information about significant
entries in these large vectors
so again think think of our
input data is representing a vector and
here you'll notice i've just switched
from n to u
and what we're going to do is is again
think of doing this
through this sketching procedure
but again i'm going to express it in
terms of of hash functions and
and operations on single items at a time
so although i can although normally i
might think of this sketch transform as
giving me a
a sort of a compact vector as my summary
i'm actually going to
reconfigure that vector as an array of w
times d it's going to be much more
convenient to think about it that way
i'm going to equip myself with the hash
functions
to map the vector entries uh from 1 up
to w
so i'm going to sort of hash entries
from from my
input vector u onto
entries and w and h i'm going to repeat
that d times
once for each of these rows
so what how does that look if i think
about where
a single index j with with weight
c goes to then in this sketch i think
about
the first hash function mapping j to
some entry
in the first row the second hash
function mapping j to some entry in the
second row
the third fourth and so on
so each entry in the vector is mapped to
one bucket in every row
and what we do in in that
bucket there is we're just going to add
up the contribution
for everything that maps into that
location
okay so that has that nice linearity
property
it means that we can think about merging
by summation
in the standard way and then we can
think about how do we estimate
go back and estimate the the weight of
an entry of a particular
entry in the vector what we'll do is
we'll go to everywhere that entry has
been mapped
in the sketch look at each of those each
of those contains a contribution
from that element along with
the contribution of all the other
elements that collided with it under
these hash functions
so we're definitely going to get some
noise but
um on the assumption that this vector
has
uh non-negative weights in it then
if we take sort of the smallest of those
places the smallest weight associated
with the places where that element falls
then that should give us
in some sense the best estimate for that
for that original element and in fact
what we can do is we can argue that the
error
that this sketch gives us is actually
quite small
what we can do is argue that
in terms of what we call f1 which is
just again the sum of all the weights
we're getting error at most epsilon if
we pick our parameter w
large enough if we pick parameter w that
proportional to
one over epsilon why is that
it actually turns out to be
fairly straightforward analysis
essentially the way the argument goes is
just to say well
look at the expectation of the error
associated with
each entry in a particular row so i'm
looking for
element uh j i look in the first row
i have in the bucket where that is
placed i have
the contribution from the element plus
the noise
from elements colliding with it and an
expectation that's just a uniform
fraction of the mass of all other
elements
so in particular with if i look at
what's the probability
that mass is more than twice its
expectation then just by immediately by
markov inequality
i know there's constant probability that
i see more than than twice the expected
mass
so if i then take the minimum over
all of those repetitions then
the probability that the minimum of
those exceeds
twice the expectation of the mass
is is diminished um down to
you know um exponentially sorry question
what do you assume about
the sketch in every word like what are
they doing what do you assume about them
so what's happening is i've taken my
whole vector
i've taken each entry of the vector
hashed it to some entry
in each row and added up just the weight
associated
with each entry so you can think of each
bucket as being the summation
of the weights of all elements that hash
into that location
how do you hash it you take your hash
function and you apply it so so in
particular i guess the
one one one question is what is the
nature of the hash function
so in this case
yeah yeah so so this is a randomly
chosen hash function drawn from
a family of pairwise independent hash
functions so essentially this this is a
hash function that is just
fairly uniformly spreading out the
entries
so i'm looking at the family of hash
functions
yes
um so what all we rely on
is the probability of a collision we can
treat uniformly and we can look at
what's the expected
mass colliding with any entry um in any
bucket in the sketch
and that is a in some sense that's a
very weak condition on the hash function
it just needs because we're looking at
expectation we're going to use linearity
of expectation
so all we need is that each pair of
elements
are mapped approximately uniformly
independent
right
okay so when you put that all together
what it actually gives you is
is the ability to recover information
about this vector so so in particular
this this gives us a biased estimator
and what it says is that our estimate in
this case
always exceeds the true weight
and with fairly high probability our
estimate is at most
epsilon times the total weight more
than the than the true answer
so what does that do it lets you go back
to that question i sort of outlined a
while ago and says how do we find the
the heavy hitters how do we find the
significant entries
in the sketch um so in fact we can you
in in the original vector
we can use the sketch to address that
question
so one way of doing that is to um
simply sort of iterate over all possible
indexes
um and test each one of them and see do
they pass this threshold are they sort
of
as the estimated mass of this index
heavy
so obviously that's rather unsatisfying
because that's a very slow way of
interrogating the structure especially
if this sketch is summarizing
a vector a very high dimension so the
alternate approach is is to start
thinking about other ways of doing this
a simple
first step is to say let's let's sort of
notionally keep a binary tree
over the input domain so that each node
in that tree corresponds to
a subset of um indices
um and and so think of
associating a weight with each node as
being the aggregation the sum
of the weights of everything in its
subtree
um and then you can sort of then you can
imagine sketching
not just the the vector at the raw level
but the vector at every level of
aggregation
and then you can follow a fairly simple
search procedure to find those large
frequencies
where we essentially start at the root
uh expand out probe the the sketches
at each subsequent level discard any
branches that correspond to
sort of light estimates and descend
until
we reach the leaves
so one one comment to make here is that
in some ways you can think of this as a
first step towards
a compressed sensing style result
what we have here is the ability to
design a measurement regime
which we can apply to a vector
that allows us to start going to that
vector and sort of pulling out what our
the significant entries and those
significant entries
are effectively going to be the best
thing to recover for our sparse recovery
so so
using fairly sort of simple technology
just simple hashing
from a weak family of hash functions a
very sparse transformation
um and and sort of interposing
essentially a
a a dyadic um
matrix in the middle to sort of uh
allow us to do the search efficiently it
gives us a result for
you know this this celebrated problem of
compressed sensing so
the results are somewhat weaker because
in particular
the guarantees that you obtain in terms
of of the probability of
successfully recovering your sparse
representation are not quite as strong
but actually there's a whole line of
work
coming from the computer science science
community that sort of starts
with these kind of techniques and
strengthens them to get
essentially results that are competitive
uh with the current
sort of best results for compressed
sensing
another sort of quicker side about this
this kind of technique has also been
used a lot
in machine learning where machine
learning you're dealing with objects
that have
uh potentially very very large numbers
of features so think about
objects representing documents where the
features might be
all pairs of words that co-occur this is
a potentially huge
feature space so if you take sort of the
standard approach and actually
fully represent that very large feature
space
then it's going to be very sort of slow
and cumbersome to work with
objects in this setting so there's a
line of work on this this idea of hash
kernels
where effectively what you do is is you
create a sketch you
apply this kind of hashing trick hashing
representation
to your very large high dimensional
feature vector
to get you something much smaller that
you can then sort of just plug in
directly
into your existing machine learning
framework and this turns out to be sort
of surprisingly effective in practice
um and and essentially you know the
reason for that is is just that
the features that turn out to be
important are preserved sort of
sufficiently well
that you can tolerate the noise that
this kind of representation
introduces for the for the less
important features
okay so that's that's the first sketch
let's see how we can sort of take this
a step further and do something uh more
complicated
uh with it um so first uh you know
that was a sketch that relied only on
the mark of inequality let's give
ourselves something slightly stronger to
work with
so mark of inequality itself directly is
quite weak
but we can also apply it to to any
random variable so in particular
we can apply it to the second moment
and when you sort of run mark of
inequality over the second moment
what you get is the chebyshev inequality
um that basically says the probability
of x being far from a random variable x
being far from its expectation
decays as a function of the variance
that should be variance of x
over the square of of the distance so
we're going to in particular we're going
to use it in this form
we're going to try and construct random
variables that represent
the estimation that our algorithm is
giving us
so that the variance is sufficiently
small as a function of a target value
a target approximation epsilon and the
expectation
of a random variable then that
immediately gives us
the probability that we're more than
epsilon
time far away from our expectation
is a constant
so let's let's put this into practice
i'm going to
talk about the the ams or on mata
segerity sketch
which is going to allow us to estimate
f2 that's the sum of the squares
of the entries in this vector and again
it turns out to be quite important
because it's at the heart of quite a lot
of streaming and non-streaming
applications
it's it's gives us dimensionality
reduction and at the end i'll talk a
little bit more about
how to interpret that so what we're
going to do is we're actually going to
take our existing
sketch structure count in sketch and and
sort of
extended a little bit further by
introducing a second set
of hash functions um
so we have one set of hash functions
that map us to entries
in the sketch we're now going to have a
second set of hash functions which are
going to map us to
plus one minus one values so using the
the terminology we've seen a lot of this
week already
we can think of these as radimaca
variables
the difference is again these are going
to be hash functions so instead of
thinking of these as fully independent
these are actually going to be
relatively low independence
so how do we change things so now again
we
when we when we have a weight c
associated with an entry j in the sketch
again we're going to to map that into
the correct location in each row and add
on the weight of that update multiplied
by the hash value
the plus one minus one hash value
associated
with um with
uh index j okay
so sort of similar picture as before
index j maps in um
but we we're multiplying now by we're
multiplying
we're summing up the weight associated
with everything
mapped to this entry but multiplied by
plus one minus one
and then to to pull out our estimation
um we're going to do something a little
bit different what we've done before
we're going to for each row we're going
to square
each entry in the sketch
sum those up and then
each of those is going to give us an
estimator for
f2 we're then going to take the median
of each of those estimates
so why does this work relatively
simple argument
what we can do is sort of look at what
do we get in each row we get the sum
over
all entries in the sketch i
of the i entering the sketch squared
times the hash value squared so we get
sort of the squares of the
individual entries um but we also get a
bunch of cross terms
of elements that collide within the
sketch
so what we get out though is because of
the the nature of these radiomic
variables the squares
whether we got a minus one or a plus one
always goes to when we square that
we always go to plus one so we get this
contribution here
of um exactly the sum of the squared
entries
and this because of the the the
independence of these two we're going to
treat these two as being uh independent
then an expectation these terms plus one
minus one products
go to zero so the expectation of our
estimator
is exactly what we want the sum of the
squares and what we have to do is argue
about the
the variant of this estimator to argue
that it gets small enough
so so to repeat the expectation of our
row estimate
is exactly the sum of the squares the
variance is
also an expectation you can churn
through this
you you go through a fair amount of
algebra to simplify this
but essentially what we're going to do
is we're going to assume that this hash
function
is now four ways independent so it
treats any collection of four terms
fully independently
so that an expectation anything with
almost anything with four terms is going
to be
drop out to zero there are only a couple
of combinations of terms we have to
worry about
and we can bound those
so in particular um anything with an odd
power
of a hash of a of a g hash
drops out to be zero an expectation what
it leaves us with
is a few terms essentially where we have
an even number
of eyes and even number of j's
and we can bound that in terms of the
square
of the target that we're looking for
scaled by
w the number of buckets in this sketch
so what that gets is it gets us to the
point where the row variant the the
variance of the estimate coming from a
single row
is bounded by the square of the thing
that we're looking for the square of f2
divided by w
so if we just set w large enough we set
w proportional to 1 over epsilon squared
and and plug through that statement of
the chebyshev inequality we have already
then it says the probability of our
estimator for row k
being more than epsilon squared times f2
away from
f2 is at most a constant is at most a
quarter
so that gets us most of the way there it
says we have constant probability
of being of a single estimate being
close to
the target how do we drive that constant
probability down to something much
smaller something more like
delta so one one obvious first thing
would be say well we got this down to
a constant just by picking the size of
the sketch w
large enough what if i just scale w up
even further can i push this down
well it's not really an effective way to
do it because if we rescale w
to make this whole probability more like
delta then
we're going to be linear in one over
delta um
that's just too costly what we're
looking for really is a cost that goes
more like logarithmic
in one over delta so
what we can do is is start using a
stronger piece of
technology we're going to use a channel
bound um
and again the way that we actually
create the turn off bound is is also by
um
applying the mark of inequality but in
this time we just apply the markup
inequality
to a random variable that's equal to the
the x
exponentiated product of a bunch of
random variables and
i don't need to go through this
calculation because actually that's
something that
joel worked through more or less
directly in his second lecture
on tuesday so what we get is is we get
a bound that says the probability that
this random variable
being a sum of independent bernoulli
trials
being far from its expectation now goes
down exponentially
in terms of that distance from the
expectation
so how can we use that what we're going
to do is is use it in the context of
this median trick
what we're going to do is um
take a bunch of repetitions of that
process that's giving us our estimator
and take the median of those
so you know why is the median going to
help us here what sort of magic about
the median
so the observation is the following that
what we're trying to do is
sort of get a good estimator and the
reason that our estimate might be
might be bad is it might be too high
meaning it might be sort of far away
from what we're looking for it might be
too low
so if we take uh independent repetitions
of this estimator and sort them
then what that does is it puts the good
estimates right there in the middle
and says that if there are bad estimates
they're sort of at the top end or at the
bottom end
so if i then take those those elements
and then take the median
those estimates and take the median of
them then
the only way that i can get a bad
estimate
to be at the median is if there's a
large number of bad estimates
so if at least half the top half of the
estimates are bad
or the bottom half of the estimates are
bad that's the only way i can get the
median
to be bad so what that means is if
i'm taking d estimations that at least
half of them must be bad
to force the median to be bad but what
we said here is that each estimate is
basically good
with probability at least three quarters
so we only expect a quarter of them to
be bad
we'd have to have twice the expected
number being bad
because of force this overall bad event
so that's exactly the situation where
you can plug in the turn-off bound
and you can say what's the probability
uh when you're
when your individual probability is a
quarter of seeing more than half of the
overall number of estimates being bad
that then gets exponentially small
in the number of estimates so now taking
just logarithmic in one over delta
number of estimates gives you that small
delta probability
of failure
okay so so why why go through in that
level of detail just because this
outline this overall outline
is one that's been used time and time
again in constructing these kind
of compact summary
approaches right you build an estimator
you argue that estimator is is has
bounded variance so it's it's close to
its expectation
with constant probability and then you
take repetitions and use a structure
like the median to
drive that constant probability of
failure down to
exponentially small probability of
failure
questions
take what to be independent exactly
so at some point you say that you need
something
yes so yeah so i i need
i need to think of these these hash
functions these hash values here
as behaving independently when i look at
any four of them
we want to minimize the amount of
randomness so so you know
if these are you know functions so if i
really materialize these as truly
independent radical random variables
then to actually store them i uh to
actually be able to
make use of them i need to store those
coin tosses
so it sort of gets back to what i was
saying at the start about randomness
being
a limited resource yeah so now how do
you build
like how much randomness do you need
um yeah
so i think i had this flashed up in the
slides earlier but let me
write out a uh four ways
uh random
um so this is a family of four wise
random hash functions
um so
um g of x
is going to be alpha x cubed
plus beta x squared
plus gamma x plus
delta
e so here i'm doing my calculations in
in the
prime field p um and
what i need to so if i pick
alpha beta gamma delta
randomly from essentially
each pick one independently from p then
over those random choices um i'm going
to have what i need
for for this random for this hash
function g
so you know why is why is that good
because all i need to do is all i need
to now do is store
alpha beta gamma and delta choices to
get
my hash function rather than having to
store something
saw a true randomness for each place
where i evaluate g
that's the game that we're playing right
we're trying to
switch from explicitly
keeping randomness to saying can i just
switch to this hash function
which is described by a very small
amount of
random parameters so we want them to
evaluate to
minus one one yeah yeah okay yeah so
that's true so
mod two and then one maps to plus one
zero maps to minus one
it's basically a counting argument you
just look at what's the probability
of uh collisions under this and uh it's
it's sort of a
fairly straightforward exercise in
combinatorics
yeah so what does this give us it gives
us
the ability to to deal with um f2
sum of the squares once you have f2
with relative error epsilon times the
the l2 norm
then switching from f2 notation to
vector notation what this says is that
i can also start estimating things like
in a product
between two vectors just by using the
fact that i can i can write um
in a product in terms of squared norms
of
x y and x plus y
and just with a bit of rearranging an
argument then
i get that guarantee so another
consequence of that
is if i take this result and say well
let
let my second vector y just be um
an indicator vector that's one at
location j
and zero everywhere else then
that inner product pulls out the jth
entry
of x uh and gives me error proportional
to epsilon times
l2 and 1 of x so this is this we call
like an l2 guarantee
this gives us sort of a account an l2
guarantee and
this sort of approach is often called
the count sketch approach
compared to we saw a similar result
earlier where we got this in terms of
epsilon times
the one norm of the vector through the
count min sketch
with that l1 guarantee
so i i said earlier this this is
essentially a form of dimensionality
reduction
so you can think of this sketching
technique as basically being a low
independence realization
of the johnson linda strauss lemma
and in fact if you look at the current
sort of best sparsest
constructions for johnson linda strauss
they have more or less the same
structure
that is they they're based on this
sparse hashing to
entries of a vector with plus or minus
one values
so how do these two approaches compare i
mean in some way you can say that
they're more or less
the same thing you know where do they
differ so in some ways
johnson strauss is a little bit stronger
because
you know as alex was saying it embeds
you directly into euclidean space
rather than embedding into in you know
rather than having this median operator
on the outside that this approach has
but also it's in some sense weaker
because um you know there's lower bounds
that say if you want to do this kind of
sparse johnson in the strauss
construction then if you think about
trying to you know what what's the
sparsity of that transform
sparsely that transform has to be at
least one over epsilon wise
in other words each entry in the vector
has to go to at least one over epsilon
different locations to get the the jl
guarantee
and you need a stronger amount of
independence of the hash functions
whereas here actually it's very very
sparse right each entry
in the vector is mapped to only log one
over delta locations in the sketch
so you know there's the potential to
incorporate that into some very very
fast code because
you know each index in the sketch is
mapped only to a very small number of
locations
okay so i'm going to talk now for a
while about a slightly different problem
relating again to vectors and relating
to frequency moments of vectors
so now i'm going to talk about this idea
of f0
f0 we can think of as being the number
of distinct items in the stream
or number of entries in the vector that
we're summarizing that have
a non-zero frequency associated with
them
the first uh algorithms for this problem
were designed around the 80s early 80s
and analyzed in the assumption of fully
independent hash functions
so i'm going to describe sort of some
what you can think of as a slight
generalization
of that algorithm which we'll call the k
minimum values algorithm
which again uses only very weak hash
functions
uh so we're in a different regime here
what we're trying to do is give a very
strong guarantee we're trying to
estimate
um number of distinct items um
up to epsilon relative error
and the difference is we're not in a
sampling regime
uh imprint effectively we do get to see
everything
but we just can't remember everything so
good turing is much more about sort of a
statistical approach this here we're in
this world where the data
is the data there is a certain number of
distinct elements
within this particular data set we get
to see everything but we can't remember
everything
so what's what's an estimator we can
build that's going to nevertheless let
us
estimate the number of distinct things
relative to that fixed true answer
so here's the approach we're going to
use
again let's now let's think of the
domain of the stream elements
uh so that the name of the input
elements say that each
element of the data is somewhere in the
range one up to m
uh and we're going to again use hash
functions that map us
into us from
items in the original space into
actually much larger space
the reason we're picking this much
larger space the hashing is just so that
we can sort of argue that
effectively in this setting we can
ignore the possibility of hash
collisions under this
hash function right there's a tiny
probability proportional to at most one
on m
that we have a collision so we're just
going to sort of condition on that event
not happening
and incur a very small penalty in our
overall success probability
so here's here's our procedure
for each element in the input that
arrives
we're going to compute the hash function
under this particular hash function
of that element and we're going to track
in this case that the t
distinct items that achieve the smallest
values
of this hash function
so you know why why might this work
what is this relying on what it's
relying on critically is if
we see the same value of i many times
then we because these hash functions are
fixed now
we get the same hash value of that so
the decision that we make is effectively
going to be the same
and that's why as soon as we have this
property with soon we use the hash
function this way
we can sort of stop worrying about the
multiplicity of individual items
and just worry about how many distinct
items there are
and what we're going to use to help
build our estimator is is this value vt
which is the the the value of the teeth
the hash
of the teeth smallest distinct value
that we see
so let me make that concrete right we
see items
uh arriving and here if i set t equals
two
i keep track of those two items with the
smallest hash values
and the corresponding hash value of the
teeth smallest of those
new item comes along and i update my
information so i only need to remember
information about these i can forget
whatever i saw about that new items come
along that doesn't change
my estimator in any way a repetition
you know i see another copy of this same
item here doesn't change
anything because it sort of has the same
hash value i recognize it
as being identical something else new
comes along
and again i update
yes
yeah so in in pretty much all of the
things i'm talking about here
we're taking advantage we're working in
a computational model where we're
assuming we're going to look at every
data item
and we're going to do something sort of
rough
typically we'll we'll treat as being
linear in the size of the input
it depends what you're measuring um so
it's it's
linear in the size of the input in terms
of the time that you take
but in terms of the size of the summary
that you build
that we're going to treat as being
sublinear
so gonna be processing every single line
gonna process every single item so
uh total running time is linear but in
terms of the
quantities like the space that we're
gonna treat as sublinear
so you're right that there are other
models where people say let's
let's be even more strictly sublinear so
let's you look at
where we can only say sample into the
data
and what you can argue is for the
problem like this
anything which is based on sampling is
basically going to fail
and the reason for that is just that you
can show that unless you're sampling a
very large fraction of the input
elements
then you can't distinguish the case
where
um the the number of distinct elements
is very small
versus the case where the number of
distinct elements is for is twice as big
say but when you're sampling thank you i
think
going back to that question yeah then
there'll be a closer connection to the
good touring
mm-hmm my work right yeah but there it
works
in some cases so what's the difference
between these two
models so in some sense the difference
here is that this is
a model that gives the computational
entity more power
it's saying if we can look at all the
elements then we we can learn more
information can we use that to get a
better estimator
so we're going to do is we're going to
try and quantify this estimator
in terms of how accurate it is as a
function of this parameter t
because t is characterizing um
the size of this the summary the size of
the information that's being kept
so you're right you know there's a whole
line of other work that i'm not really
talking about that looks at
sampling estimators that looks at sort
of scaling computations
based on on that kind of sublinear
approach um
so you know that's that's definitely you
know a whole other line of work that i
don't really have time to
get into but it's another approach to
this sort of scaling up to large
computations like this
okay
so you know how or why should this work
well the idea is that
again if if this hash function that
we're using is reasonably uniform
then if we look at where the teeth
smallest hash value should be
that should should roughly be sort of a
uniform fraction
uh a t over f zero fraction
along this line right so here we're
mapping items
along this range so this this fraction
should if we scale it up should tell us
how many distinct items there are
so that's pretty much how we build our
estimator
what we do is is we take
t over v t and use that to scale
this range m cubed
right so we look at sort of m cubed over
v t is
what fraction along this range we are
and we scale that up by t
how do we analyze this what we basically
do is we look at well
how can things go wrong so let's hope
for the best and
plan for the worst so what's one way it
could go wrong one way could go wrong is
based on
the true value of f zero what can happen
in terms of this estimator what could
happen is
we might be too high you know we want to
be
at most one plus epsilon times f0 so if
this estimate is above f0
what does that really mean it means that
we sort of
relative to this
boundary point where we should have been
we saw too many things we should have
seen about t
things under here we saw a lot more than
we expected
under this threshold value
so what that means is we can say you
know the number of items that we saw
that hash below that
fixed threshold was more than t so that
that led to us having a bad estimate
that we can just do some rearrangement
and look at what's the probability
of for any individual item hashing
outside of that range
um and if we then use that to sort of
look at how many
items do we expect
we can argue that the expected number of
items hashing in this range
looks small right so we're saying we've
got more than t actually we expect
roughly one minus epsilon times t items
to fall in that range so we can again
follow the outline that i talked about
already look at the variance of this
estimator
variance this quantity and show that
similarly the variance of this quantity
is not too high and here again we're
relying on
independence in particular we're relying
on the fact that we can look at the
um the variance of this random variable
which is basically the summation
of a whole bunch of random variables
talking about individual events
we can sum those up because basically
because
each event is pairwise independent and
that's all we need to be able to sum
those variances
so again we just sort of plug in
chebyshev inequality
and what we get is the probability that
we saw too many things
hashing below that threshold
we can express in terms of the variance
which we can then express
in terms of t and epsilon
so what do we do we just choose t to be
large enough
in this case t looks again proportional
to one over epsilon squared
to make that probability of this bad
event being at most a constant
right so what we do is we work through
just what's the probability that we see
too many things
hashing into too small a range argue
that this shouldn't be too likely based
on a function of t
and choose t to make the probability of
this bad event at most a constant
so what this gives us is the probability
that we see
that our estimate is too large we've now
argued is at most a fifth
and then using essentially the same
argument just sort of changing
uh changing the terms around you can
similarly say the probability that our
estimate is too small
that we didn't see enough items hashing
below a different threshold
is also most of fifth um
so apart from those two bad events
then we've got a good probability at
least a half
at least three-fifths that our estimate
is not too small and is not too large
so again we're in this situation where
we have an estimator
which a single instance of that
estimator we believe is going to be good
at least a constant fraction of the time
so again we're going to amplify that
probability
so the probability of failure is very
small by repeating it log one over delta
times in parallel
with different and those repetitions are
based on
drawing different draws from that family
of hash functions
and again we just plug in that same
analysis that i talked about before
where we take those estimates we take
the median of those to
to push down that probability
so in terms of those costs i talked
about at the start
um what are we incurring we're choosing
we just have to store those hash values
t
so that gives us a dependency on one
over epsilon squared
log m much stronger than than we'd get
from
uh something like good turing to give
this relative error guarantee and
actually
you know subsequent workers has even
sort of said well
let's turn this multiplicative log
factor into an additive log factor
by more hashing tricks and more sort of
representation tricks
and in terms of processing each update
to this summary structure
what do i have to do i just have to do
this hashing i have to do this
comparison
with the teeth the current teeth
smallest hash value and update
uh if something's not already present so
this again we can do very quickly indeed
effectively constant time per update
um so just one thing to sort of mention
briefly which is that
so i said at the start well typically
we're not going to care too much about
constants
this this notion of of counting this
notion of counting the number of
distinct events turns out to be a fairly
fundamental kind of
computation a lot of big data
applications
so there has been a lot of interest for
this kind of
algorithm in really engineering it as
much as possible
and really actually hammering down on
those constants
so the current state of the art is
something a little bit different to what
i showed you something called the
hyperloglog algorithm
i won't really describe the details um
but you know it's it's something where
people have really focused on
saying exactly how many bits do we need
in our hash function how do we represent
this compactly what kind of tricks can
we do
to really squeeze down that leading
constant so for this
this algorithm we're still using sort of
one over epsilon squared space
but that log factor gets crushed down to
a log log factor
which in turn gets treated as a constant
when people actually go off and
implement this
and it has that some additional
flexibility
because you can reason not just about
the number of distinct elements that
you've seen summarized by one sketch
structure
but you can start looking at not just
unions between
different sketches but also
intersections
so in particular what you can do is as i
said before
so by analogy to what i was saying about
f2 estimation you can similarly use
uh identities like the fact that the
size of the intersection between two
sets can be expressed as
the sum of the size of the two sets less
the size of the union
and so you can take your sketch for
set a your sketch for set b merge them
together to get a sketch for a union b
and plug in the estimates for each of
these now in both cases and in this case
you have to
exercise a little bit of caution because
the error that you obtain
you shouldn't expect to be able to
estimate this quantity very strongly it
turns out that's
estimating the size of intersection is
going to be one of the fundamentally
hard problems that we obtain so we don't
not going to expect relative error here
but instead we're going to expect error
that scales in this case
uh proportional to the square root of
the product of the size of these two
sets
so this error term is going to sort of
mask out the true answer for very small
intersections but for
decent sized intersections this kind of
thing is nevertheless going to work
quite well
and and one can take this approach and
generalize it to sort of higher
order intersections via inclusion
exclusion
um i'm not going to talk in in any depth
about bloom filters i just wanted to
mention bloomfilter
because again um in terms of
how people are using these kind of
algorithms in practice
then i think bloom filter is an example
of a sketch
that is very widely used
in a number of applications so what what
does bloomfield do it basically
compactly encodes set membership
so it's an interesting kind of sketch
because
it's only very lightly sublinear in
terms of its space right what bloom
filter allows us
is to represent um
a set of n elements
in space that's proportional to n bits
but what it gives us is just that that
saving going from potentially large
exact representations of elements down
to this sort of compact bitter a
representation in terms of bits is
enough for saving that this alone is
sort of at the heart
of of many of the the sort of big data
applications
um people are looking at these days
and and for some reason it's seems to
generate a highly active research area
particularly within say the networking
community so uh pretty much every
networking conference these days seems
to have
several papers on innumerable variations
of bloomfield as a way of representing
set information
so i have a few minutes left and then i
think we should probably
wrap it up for the day so i just wanted
to talk briefly about a few other
directions where people have been
looking at
sketching streaming computations over
large vectors
so we talked about frequency moments
being that the sum of the kth power
of the frequencies and
we looked at f0 counting number of
distinct elements we looked at
f2 counting the sum of the squares of
the element frequencies
so the last you know the next thing to
look at is to say well what about k
greater than 2 so i won't talk about
this algorithm in any depth
um there's an algorithm going back to
the the lonnie tell
paper from 96 that comes up with a nice
estimator for this
based on the sort of the streaming view
of the world where you get to see each
update
based on building a nice estimator for
this and arguing it has exactly the
right expectation
and bounded variance
which gives not the best bounds for this
and and something which doesn't quite
meet our definition
of a sketch because it doesn't have this
linearity property so what i'll do
instead is
is in the next talk tomorrow morning
talk in a little bit more detail about a
different
approach to estimating high frequency
moments which has those
linear sketch properties
alex in in his presentation on
embeddings talked
about essentially combinations of
frequency moments right he talked about
a particular combination where you look
at the sum of the squares
of values of of l infinity applied to
l1 norm so more generally you can start
thinking about other ways of combining
norms right instead of just wanting a
number of distinct items you could look
at
something based on say that the sum of
the squares
of number of distinct items
which you can think of as being you know
you have your input now represented as a
matrix
you want to count number of distinct
items on each row and then look at the
squares
of those counts um
and there's been a variety of techniques
approach that the general idea there
is to start looking at the existing
sketch techniques that we have already
and start reasoning about how we can
compose them how you can
sort of take an inner sketch for the
initial computation
and then sort of wrap that into an outer
level sketch for the next level
computation
as you can imagine it's it's not really
that trivial to
analyze these kind of things the
constants blow up the size of the
sketches blow up
and you tend to need a new analysis
every time you start doing these kind of
more complex combinations of
computations to
get the overall guarantee
another approach another set of problems
that people looked at quite a lot is
questions about range efficiency so i've
talked about the input model where each
update
in the input gives you some information
about some new
arrival individually but sometimes i
want to think about we might want to
think about the input
specifying say ranges so we think you
know we think the input
gives us sort of the range a b meaning
that we want to
suddenly insert a copy of item you know
a a plus one a plus two all the way up
to b
so certainly you could just unpack that
range and take time linear in the size
of that range
but what you'd really like to do is is
do things range efficiently
so people look to things like range
efficient f0 by saying
when you take the aggregation of all
these ranges how much do you end up
covering
um there's a nice approach which
essentially
uses a sketch very much like the the
cayman and value sketch
but just sort of unpacks those hash
computations and looks at exactly what's
the impact on the hash functions
as these indices increment and sort of
very efficiently computes the impact on
those hash function pulls out
which are the subset of these items that
hash into that range
of the prefix of the hash range
people also looked at that for range
efficient f2
and most recently going from a range to
a rectangle so now you have
uh essentially two dimensional ranges
and again how do you
very efficiently process the updates uh
again by unpacking the structure of
those hash functions
okay so i think that's probably a good
time to start wrapping things up now
um for today so i wanted just to at the
end put up a couple of trailers for
forthcoming attractions um so firstly
andrew mcgregor sitting at the back
wearing a very similar looking shirt
is going to be giving a mini 10 lecture
course
on streaming data stream and data stream
computations
starting i think in early october and
secondly this idea of succinct
data representations via sketches is
something that's going to get covered
in much more depth in a workshop not
next week but the following week
in this very room so i'd certainly
encourage you
those of you that are sticking around
over the semester to
interact and participate in both of
those
and tomorrow we'll pick up again
on this topic of advanced topics looking
at
things based around sampling some matrix
computations
and some lower bounds results okay
so that's probably the right time to
stop thank you for your attention
any further questions
okay good so i think we pick up again
tomorrow morning bright and early
oh